>> Sean: Professor Brailsford - a lot of people
talk about von Neumann architecture and
we've talked about Babbage; we've talked
about Turing. Who was von Neumann ?!
>> DFB: We've done a lot about Turing; we've
done a fair bit about Babbage, in the
generation earlier. In fact a lot of
people, I guess, in the English-speaking
world would regard Turing, in some way, as
being the Father of Computing. He came up
with this very important result, in the
mid-thirties, about what was computable,
and as we now know. to his credit. he
wasn't at all afraid to burn himself with a
soldering iron and try to create
hardware. Which he did at Bletchley Park
during the war. So, yes, if he's the Father,
if Babbage was the Grandfather and if Ada,
Countess of Lovelace, was the Great-Aunt,
then who on earth was John von Neumann?
And why is he mentioned alongside Turing?
Well right at the outset let's say John
von Neumann was the impossibly talented,
impossibly charismatic, very wealthy,
Uncle to computing. It was he that, in the
mid-1940s, in a way, made it all happen by
the force of his own personality. And
kept it, not just in an enclosed
community, but encouraged all those who
wanted to build general-purpose
computers to come along to this Summer
School and do it.  But that really, I guess,
is in the future. It's where we've got to
get to in the von Neumann story. But, yes,
you're quite right Sean, to say that one
of the first phrases that almost any
computer scientist hears about is The
von Neumann Architecture for computers,
which to a large extent we still follow
even now - all of, what 60-70 years later.
So, we've mentioned EDSAC before, we'll
be coming back to mention this very
important early computer again. But it is
a von Neumann machine and all it's
saying is [that] it's very simple to build a
computer. You need a Store, or Memory as
it's more commonly called nowadays, to
hold your instructions and your data.
You need a
control unit, often called a CPU now. And
you need an arithmetic capability - the
ALU, the arithmetic and logic unit. Again
many of you will know in modern chips
those two are often combined into what
we just call "the CPU chip" nowadays.
And you need input devices of various sorts
leading back to people's Teletypes [with]
input/output devices for backup storage,
disk and so on. You need to be able to do
input and output. So there it is. It's
just one, two, three, four, five boxes - that
is the von Neumann architecture. And it's
very, very similar today. There was a big
debate at the time about that Store that
Memory. Shouldn't you, for safety's sake,
put the instructions of your program in
a different sort of memory to your data?
Wouldn't it be safer to do that and
better in some ways? On the other hand,
clearly, if you've got a good memory
technology, that works, the temptation
might be just to put them [instructions and data]
in separate areas of that same technology and try
and take some sort of precaution about
them not interfering with each other. In
EDSAC the only way to get into a
subroutine and get back out of it again
was to over-write part of your program
instructions! Let's just return back to
this incredible character John von
Neumann. How does he fit in alongside
Alan Turing? Well, like I said, he's the
older, impossibly talented, Uncle. Did
Turing and von Neumann know each other?
Oh yes they did! They were both, basically,
trained as mathematicians. Von Neumann -
it's hard to know where to begin and
where to end. You can't exaggerate enough
about how
good he was. He was Hungarian and his
Hungarian name - where they give surnames
first - was, I think, Neumann Janos.
His father was very, very wealthy and
when one was quite young the family
became ennobled in Hungary. [They] became
basically at the level of Baron -
hereditary Baron I think
over here. Janos was very talented; he was
a childhood prodigy. He could divide one
eight-digit number by another eight
digit-number in a fraction of a second
when he was aged about 6. He loved
history; he was a multi-talented polymath
he easily came top of the class he
effortlessly took in detail. And that's
the first thing that all of his
mathematics contemporaries said about
him was his sheer speed of picking up
new ideas and seeing the ramifications
of them. So he was notorious even as a
teenager, and as a maths undergrad. He did
his early education I think up to PhD
level in Budapest. He almost naturally
ended up at a place we mentioned before
in connection with Godel and Hilbert.
I'm talking, of course, about Gottingen
University in Germany. So Neumann Janos
makes the journey, via a PhD, to becoming
effectively the research assistant
to the superstar David Hilbert at
Gottingen. But because his family
had been ennobled he's not Janos Neumann
any more - Neumann
Janos sorry  - he's Johann von Neumann
- impossibly talented. Hilbert his
supervisor, at a seminar given by Johnny,
John,  Johann (!)  asked who his tailor was.
Because his impossibly smart
pinstripe suit was just a complete
knockout. So he was a legend almost the
moment he got there and did some
fabulously important work there. It was
obvious that for somebody of his talents
he was going to get a full Professorship
very quickly indeed. I think he became
impatient, waiting for it to happen at
any German university. So, in the late thirties
- '37-'38?  Somewhere around there anyway -
Anyway he got an offer from Princeton, in
New Jersey. And that was, I don't know,
very timely. It all fitted in together
very well. As part of his tours of Europe,
giving seminars, and on his way to
Princeton, I think he met Turing in the
mid-thirties in Cambridge. Because he
gave seminars there
and I think a lot of mutual respect grew
up. I mean, obviously, Turing being in awe of
von Neumann wouldn't be so exceptional.
But after that 1936 paper of Turing's,
about decidability, following on from
Godel and all that, von Neumann rated
Turing - there was no question about that.
This was evidenced by the fact, you will
recall - those of you who have seen my previous
videos - that Turing also took a
sabbatical and worked with Alonzo Church at Princeton.
Well, von Neumann was there by that time.
Von Neumann was such a superstar, they not only
made him [full] Professor of Mathematics at
Princeton, at an absurdly early age -
probably about 30, something like that.
But some of you will recall, right next
door to Princeton - about a mile and a
half across the meadows - is the Institute
for Advanced Study which had been
endowed in the early 1930s by a
multi-millionaire. And this really was
the ultimate Club to be invited to join.
You've got to be of the quality of
Einstein, who accepted the invitation.
Hermann Weyl one of the founders of
quantum mechanics; Godel - we know about
Godel. Godel was invited to just come
to IAS - Institute for Advanced Study at
Princeton - stay as long as you like. Yes,
you're a Professor; everything found: food
accommodation; the lot. All we want is to
have the greatest minds here. Von Neumann
was offered a professorship in that
community, I think at age 35 - maybe
slightly younger. Unbelievably young. He'd
hardly been at Princeton a year or two, as
an ordinary mathematics professor.
Everybody thought "This is a truly
phenomenal person". He reminded many
people of absolute superstars like
Newton, Gauss, Euler, Einstein, Hilbert
himself. Even at early to mid-
thirties they could see that potential
in him, there. So, yes, Turing visits
Princeton in 1938 - worked with Alonzo
Church - but also of course had frequent
interactions at seminars with von Neumann
And then came the big question,
if you recall, for Alan Turing: "Should I
return to England and do my patriotic
duty?" According to Andrew Hodges'
definitive biography of Turing,
Turing's father was all for Turing
staying in Princeton, you know: "Keep out
of the war; get a prestigious mathematics
job". And that was underlined by the fact
that von Neumann offered Turing a job. He
basically said: "Turing, would you like to
be my research assistant at the
Institute for Advanced Study?" Now
Turing could see, straight away, that would
just make you as a mathematician.
You were invited, by the great von Neumann,
to be his research assistant, at IAS!
Only problem was, I think, first of all, I think
Alan Turing did feel a certain
patriotism in wanting to come home and
do his bit. There was also the worry that
at that time von Neumann had not
properly got into computing - he'd not
turned his considerable talents to
considering it - and for the research
assistantship he wanted Alan Turing to
do quantum mechanics, another of von
Neumann's great loves. And I don't think
Turing was keen on that because he
knew from experience, at Cambridge, where
he'd tried doing mathematical physics, it
really wasn't his arena at all. So he
politely declined with great thanks, came
back to England and the rest, if you like,
is more or less history. Now there's
"Johnny", as he'd now become. Johann von
Neumann speaker of four, five languages
including Italian and English, once he'd
transferred from Gottingen to Princeton,
wanted to become the all-American genius.
So he was ... on more formal occasions he
was just John von Neumann but to his
friends he was "Johnny". You can't
exaggerate enough! I mean, his wife said: "He
can count everything but calories". He was
fond of food and drink; the champagne
parties! the glitz! the glamour! the
girlfriends! Good old Johnny - he
absolutely was the antithesis of the
shy mathematician. He was all-
encompassing and everybody who met him
was just stunned by how he could see
his way through
problems in no time flat. And just do
impossible things. And so he was there, in
a very ,very nice position, Institute for
Advanced Study, even before the
Americans joined the war. But he stayed
there throughout the war. But being who
he was he was endlessly in demand to be
a consultant and, most famously, along
with people like J Robert Oppenheimer he
was one of the consultants employed on
the Manhattan Project - the atomic bomb and
the hydrogen bomb. But he was used by the
Army, the US Navy, the Air Force
- everybody wanted Johnny as their
consultant. And this even included, as the
war developed, the fact that one of the
earliest computers which we have
mentioned in a previous video was
University of Pennsylvania, Moore School
of Engineering. They helped develop the
ENIAC which, if you remember, was a vacuum
tube computer running on decimal
arithmetic and initially devoted to
gunnery trajectory calculations. It was a
bit late in 1946 to be in direct
strategic use in gunnery, Actually Johnny,
who by this time *of course* was a
consultant to the Moore School, devised a
way, I think, to turn ENIAC into being a
general purpose computer, although it
wasn't a very efficient one, and I
believe he used it for some calculations
relevant to the atomic bomb and all that
kind of thing. The natural question
arising with everybody at the end of the
war went like this: "We all know - or even
though it's top-secret at Bletchley Park
we have heard gentle rumours - that
computers are being developed all over
the place and you've always got to say:
Are they special-purpose? Are they
general-purpose? Are they
binary? Are they decimal? Are they fully
electronic? Or are they electromechanical?
And literally there must have been at
least a dozen machines around that
satisfied some of these criteria. If you
ask Germans about "Who's the father of
computing?", they'll  say "Konrad Zuse", He
developed electromechanical
machines that were Turing-complete and
calculated things. But they never got
beyond electromechanical. You get on to
electronic ones - you get Atanasoff
and Berry's electronic, valve driven,
thing - special purpose though! Could solve
certain differential equations. And even
Tommy Flowers, and Colossus, we know,
special purpose: could decrypt Tunny traffic -
Lorenz cipher as it later become
known as. So, you've got everything
happening that if it's general-purpose
it's not yet electronic; if it's
special-purpose it is electronic but we
want it to be general-purpose. So, at the
end of the war was the perfect time to
get everybody together and say: "Look, now
that the war's over we all want to find
the way to do it correctly. To build
general-purpose, probably binary-based
because they're more reliable, all
electronic digital computers. How do we
do it"? And who better to lead the charge and
run a Summer School, and be associated
with it, than uncle Johnny of course!
And the Moore School at Pennsylvania, to their
great credit, did this. They decided that
the successor to ENIAC would be a thing
called EDVAC. They said, yeah, it's
going to take us three or four years to do
this but in the meantime here we are,
1946, why not all of you, all over the
world, who are interested in the quest to
build general-purpose, all electronic,
digital computers, probably based on the
binary system ... we'll hold a Summer School
in the Moore School of Engineering, 1946,
welcome everybody. Did Turing go to it?
He was, I believe, at that time at the
National Physical Laboratory in the UK
No he didn't.
Hated conferences did Turing. He wasn't
a clubbable character. He  couldn't stand
small-talk. Classic shy mathematician not
at all like
von Neumann, right? So Turing wasn't, if you
like, the UK representative there. And one
wonders whether he would also been held
back by Bletchley Park and the Official
Secrets Act because he'd only just left a
few years before. The representative from
the UK was somebody who was Turing's exact
contemporary. They had both done
mathematics in the early 1930s, at
Cambridge. They had both got first-class
degrees. Did they get on? Not very well!
But who's this other person? His name is
Maurice Wilkes - Maurice Vincent Wilkes - and
by the vagaries of job allocations
around about World War II, he didn't end
up at Bletchley Park, did Maurice, he ended
up in radar. But he knew enough about
mathematics and electronics to be in a
good position to do, or make, a von
Neumann machine in the UK in the period
from about 1946 onwards. But we'd better
stop there because Maurice and his EDSAC
is an extra story.